i think people have dramatically become  more social everybody's talking about  like our kids are not social anymore i  don't see it i've been able to have  dramatically more relationships because  of the internet's real ones or just  online dramatically real ones see i  don't have a difference between online  and real you guys been dming back and  forth oh long time finally get to meet  the guy in person you know people love  to [ __ ] on technology oh social's bad  for it is this the first time we're  meeting i feel like i've known him for  15 [ __ ] years people love to look at  the negative i tend to look at the  positive about things it's crazy the  emotion and the energy i feel and that  would not be possible without social